they turned up in their thousands angry
and somber for the killing of their
leaders by the United States
chanting anti us slogans the protesters
included families of the supporters of
iran-backed fighters in Iraq God willing
the resistance to defeat the Americans
will continue and this gathering is a
response to American attacks on our
leaders and victory is coming most flags
at the funeral of Qasem Soleimani and
Almaty L Mohandas represent the various
fighting groups which constitute the
popular mobilization forces Iraqis see
the assassinations as a violation of
their sovereignty and of the rules of
engagement by US forces individuals the
US has called terrorists and public
enemies our heroes too many in Iraq
that's why the current and former prime
ministers came to pay their respects the
leader of the popular mobilization
forces who is also the National Security
Advisor also walked with the procession
America America's tyranny will fade as
it exceeds its limits with arrogance we
demand the Iraqi government and
Parliament legislate to make Iraq
stronger with the popular mobilization
forces the army and its people on Sunday
we want good news from Parliament no
procrastination and no delays we must
get rid of dirty forces standing on
Iraqi chests the banners of Hezbollah
brigades are prominent the US State
Department has declared the Shia armed
group a terrorist organization its
fighters were recently targeted by the
US on the iraq-syria border and that was
the reason cited by pro-iranian groups
for attacking the u.s. embassy compound
in Baghdad Imam al Mohandas was the
brigades former leader who said man we
lost commanders of the hasad who
liberated Iraq liberated provinces
occupied by ISIL Iraq forced on behalf
of all the world this violation has all
Iraqi people angry and condemning this
awful crime the bodies of the two
leaders traveled from holy shrines in
Baghdad to Karbala and Najaf where Abu
Maciel Mohandas will be buried while
Soleimani is very ill is to take place
in Iran receiving messages of support
for Iraq sovereignty president Barron
Saleh has spoken to world leaders
including the Turkish and French
presidents they agreed on taking
measures to prevent Iraq from becoming a
battleground for other countries to
settle their scores MPs and commanders
of pro-iranian groups say in death Qasem
Soleimani could achieve the victory he
wanted to expel US troops from Iraq the
parliaments extraordinary session is
already under mounting public pressure
to legislate against the presence of US
forces in Iraq but with a weak interim
government with limited legislative
powers the government is likely to not
meet those expectations Zalman Javed al
Jazeera Baghdad